you're watching film courage yeah
radio show here with the one event Peter
Alliss hello most listened to show all
of our 64 episodes so tell us about
movie buzz I started about two and a
half years ago I back in high school I
did a an article called movie buzz and
my god to New York for films go excited
to start broadcasts myself on YouTube to
those lot different people kind of doing
that as well I really want to get
involved with the community and I really
wanted to promote craft and after the
years I've done really wanted to get a
movie from one become a filmmaker now
hosting so I was trying to improve my
craft and that sense of trying to have a
better host heard if you want to become
a legitimate movie critic so it's
definitely great in a launching pad
so your YouTube channel is moving bus
yes because I just Eddie Bobo got that
for me so now that now links to my site
so that helps lodges it was safe for all
this p.m. can now say youtube.com slash
movie pods and directions back to me
let's go before I try to get the head
trinket that username Missoni had it but
no one used it for like years and then
basically we look like get it pick it up
able to say that these are people don't
find me that way that have movie buzz as
part of my URL so now you've come out
from the east coast to have in 2010 the
brunch spot here Louie was great was
last year's gathering in New York 79 was
found my first way--but YouTube
experience and that I heard that this
was going on especially this way for
organized this year because we have an
actual hotel in conference rooms and
Caesar fellow people to come out but
this is bitterly granite I've got a lot
new people who are gonna go burn tables
no the New York one but this has been
her looks crazy man belonging to that
ball a la grecque new connections hello
my friends the youtubers who live in
California now
I'm meeting kitchen with them hood they
want to do that with me when I come down
here in the fall so it's gonna be and I
went on the computer this morning and I
saw that you posted I think something
last night here over 5,000 views as of
this morning like 10:00 a.m. California
time so tell us the hits to your channel
does that matter to you what does that
translate
buzz for you well I'm never I'm not
complaining about any other babies like
me it's nice to see but I mostly focus
on every episode trying to make it
better than the last I wish might
improve my craft in one way or the other
but it's mostly about practice for me in
fact that people like it that's great
that helps me out oops I get feedback
but I mostly do it just to better myself
and the more times I do it the better
managers are done let me get back to
what my first episodes which were not
the best but to see the progression of
stuffs I've done and my consistency with
that it's always it's mostly for me to
build my my status more than like trying
to get the number one more subscribe and
the viewers good suit gives me more
exposure to it and because of that new
opportunities and new people it's kind
of Google myself now but yeah it's well
it's a lot of fun I mostly do it just
because I want to become better at what
I'm doing is that it's not a competition
for me it's work I love doing it I would
still do it even if like you're watching
and lastly have you gained any insights
from us and the panel's gone on this
weekend most the panel's now is mostly
talking about how do you experience you
see how everyone kind of came to be
musicians from all eras or but the
Buckley's think he was doing
it's only it's more like little
inspiring stories very wise things and
then see like Oh like their success kind
of inspires me and what else the kind of
quality their own thing and there are
goals guys work hard they work really
hard so I'm kind of to want to live up
to level like also they're doing now is
very low but if we're like the new
youtubers are kind of coming up now it's
really great for them to learn about
kind of stuff that we're doing outs and
I was - we're kind of know is it now -
YouTube if the new youtubers were here
this year it's really great for them to
kind of pick abundance little tips and
tricks for their channels
you